hello everyone I'm Patti Kim today we're
heading off to New Zealand well known as
a thrill-seekers paradise hey this is
the country that invented bungee jumping
of all things and that's just the
beginning
so get ready and pack your sense of
adventure as we escape to this rugged
South Pacific nation if you're looking
for an adrenaline high there may be no
easier place to find it than you zealand
after all this is the country that
invented commercial bungee jumping
pioneered right here at the Kawara
bridge for more ways to just feel glad
you're alive wander into the mountain
resort of Queenstown New Zealand's
epicenter of adventure and we quite
proudly call ourselves a venture capital
the world there are so many adventures
of history and family worked it out you
did one of every type of activity you'd
be here for 60 days it's tough enough to
jump at Kawara but at other sites in
Queenstown the drop is enough to make
adventure seem like lunacy people
have to really try hard to jump other
ones who get the most out of it at least
that's the theory to see Queens towns
rivers from another perspective tried
roaring down one in a jet boat
there's no propellers so the boat can
operate in just a few inches of water
jet boats were invented to navigate New
Zealand's shallow rivers but it turned
out they were just as effective scaring
the daylights out of customers paying
for the privilege Queenstown has enough
adventure activities to easily fill a
week and you can often get your thrills
on a budget by booking several
adventures at once and while Queenstown
offers one-stop adventure shopping there
are plenty of other places in New
Zealand to get your pulse racing on the
North Island the volcanic area of
Rotorua is home to geysers great hiking
and an odd orb all desorb
just rolling around which way you go on
slidin over and under each other david
akers his brother and another New
Zealander
invented the zorb in 1994 for some
people it's the bungee jump now I'm
never gonna do anything more interesting
than this and it's terrifying for them
might seem like a good idea at the time
first-timers often feel anxious as the
zorb heads downhill but just about the
time you think this is an activity
better suited to hamsters than humans
the Zord literally knocks you off your
feet you can't steer it or stop it yet
you can't help but enjoy it so if you're
headed to New Zealand and you've got a
little spare cash and a fairly strong
stomach you too can do something crazy
and live to tell the tale